this Friday the SpaceX Dragon capsule is
set to make its way back to Earth from
the international space station the
unmanned spacecraft docked with the
station Sunday it is the first
commercially built spacecraft capable of
carrying people to do so the ISS is home
to a rotating group of astronauts Peggy
Whitson became the first female
commander there in 2007 she spent six
hundred and sixty-five days in space
that's more time than any other American
and Whitson also completed ten
spacewalks during her career the most
bio woman in our note to self Ceres she
admitted that her success came with
challenges ignore the naysayers ignore
the people who say you can't become an
astronaut instead use it as motivation
it will be ten years of applying before
ever becoming an astronaut the
rejections will be discouraging but in
your typical style you will just keep
trying now retired astronaut Peggy
Whitson to the table she's here as part
of our coverage leading up to
International Women's Day friday good
morning okay I started to get teary eyed
I think you did what you have
accomplished is so incredible so it's so
great to have you here and NASA just
announced there is going to be the first
all-female spacewalk we'll take those
March 29th we think of space it tends to
be a male-dominated field how do we get
more women involved in what you've done
well I think we need to start earlier I
think it's really important for us to
teach young ladies young and but pretty
much anybody we need everyone to feel
like science is cool being a geek is
cool and keep that going because right
now I think maybe with social media and
different things young people have
different priorities on their lives and
we need to maybe emphasize the fact that
a career is important but I also think
that Universal message who were those
naysayers who were those people that
told you you couldn't do it I I think it
was just unbelievable from where I came
from in rural Iowa it was pretty much
unbelievable that I could do these
things luckily I had
parents who were so supportive all the
time I know but taking you right in your
nose itself that it took you ten years
of rejection yeah I'm thinking by year
eight I'd be thinking well maybe I
should go in so you go from ten years of
rejection they now call you space ninja
is your nickname which I like why is it
after you get that many rejections you
still keep going what was the
fascination for you about wanting to be
in space I wanted to go into space since
I was nine when I watched the Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin walk on the
moon and I think that got further
reinforced when I graduated from high
school and they selected the first
female astronauts and among them were
two medical doctors and one biochemist
and which I ended up getting my degree
and which made me think that hey it
really might be possible for me to
become an astronaut but ten years of
applying that was maybe not the smartest
thing in the world but it was yeah but
what's interesting too and people say
well white you know how did you get
lucky enough to be the first commander
on the station or the first chief female
chief of the astronaut office and it was
that 10 years yeah that 10 years what
made me a better astronaut it made me
more prepared I was doing negotiations
in Russia developing working with small
teams and I was the leading and all of
that actually made me you were ready
that's a good man yeah okay go back to
your parents for a second because some
of us are and and when we hear about
stem people think of the classroom and
but but the parents create the structure
in the groundwork for young women and
young men to be able to kind of reach
after their dreams so what was it in
particular that your parents I think
they just believed in me I remember my
mom telling me when I was about 12 that
I could be anything I wanted and I
believed her and I I think there's a
time frame at least when I go out to
speak to young people that I notice you
know from about eight to ten eleven
twelve in that time frame children are
more receptive to you
and you're telling them things are
possible and in your note to self
you wrote seeing the earth for the first
time in orbit you will be surprised that
you never noticed the quality and
texture of colors really makes you
appreciate the planet that we live
absent of the moon that was a national
project that was one in which space
exploration was something a president
talked about all the time what's your
feeling about where our country is now
in terms of thinking about exploration
has it moved just all to the private
sector now is that a good thing
we've definitely not moved to the
private sector there's still a NASA in
spite of the fact that we haven't
launched astronauts from the US and
several years we're still the lead of
the International Space Station has been
generating incredible amounts of
scientific research and those things
that we are learning up there how to
maintain our bone density for instance
it's going to be beneficial for us to do
these longer missions going out to Mars
etc so all of that is a process and I
think that we're in an interesting place
now that that commercialization
combining with government like for
instance SpaceX arriving with the Ripley
onboard this last weekend as Elon called
you for advice the you know we're
combining this commercial capability
it's giving us a little bit more
flexibility maybe a little more
innovative ways of doing things that
aren't quite as easy to do in a National
Bureau cracy but NASA's got this huge
database of information and knowledge
and experience and the combination of
those I think can be very fruitful which
is the plan they have for the lunar
gateway which will be a small station
that'll orbit the moon and we'll be able
to do missions down there robotic
missions and human missions down to the
moon's surface testing out things like
solar electric propulsion
using the regolith to mine materials
that we're going to use either for fuels
and use that space station as a fuel
depot just those what is a great day in
space look like you know whenever you go
back in Harvey mature Peggy thank you
thank you so much great to have you on
set